du jour avec Gauthier ravinsky
[Musique]
voilà première rencontre bonjour entre
les deux hommes une rencontre finalement
hautement symbolique dans le contexte
que l'on connaît oui parce que
si vous avez des hésitations du côté
occidental sur la manière dont il faut
aider l'Ukraine ou même souvenez-vous
quand l'invasion russes a commencé
beaucoup d'occidentaux pensaient que la
chose serait terminée dans la semaine
comme le voulait Poutine et que donc il
fallait faire le gros dos en attendant
de voir à quelle sauce Poutine voudrait
manger l'Ukraine et puis il y a eu cette
résistance et puis il y a eu cette
résilience et puis il y a
les capacités militaires et surtout les
capacités politiques du Ukraine qui est
renaissante et qui est incarnée par
Zelenski dont on ne pensait pas vu son
passé d'acteur qu'il puisse être à la
hauteur de cette tâche et donc qui en
premier quasiment en premier a pris ce
chemin de l'aide inconditionnel à
l'Ukraine c'est Varsovie de manière très
claire avec d'abord l'accueil de
réfugiés Ukrainiens avec aussi des dons
des livraisons d'armes de plus en plus
sophistiqués de plus en plus imposante
et de plus en plus nécessaire à
l'Ukraine et quand ça n'était pas le cas
Varsovie on s'en rappelle plaider de
manière très ferme pour que on accède
aux souhaits des Hélène ski et de
l'Ukraine ça a été le cas vous savez
pour les chars vous en souvenez pour les
chars notamment les Léopards les chars
allemands alors évidemment dans cette
affaire Varsovie se refait une virginité
on va dire sur le plan européen puisque
la Pologne a été montrée du doigt à
plusieurs reprises pour on va dire tout
ça de manière euphémistique les libertés
qu'elle prend avec l'État de droit que
cela concerne la justice que cela
concerne les homosexuels que cela
concerne l'avortement les femmes etc
donc à la faveur si j'ose dire de cette
guerre en Ukraine Varsovie devient
finalement le du vilain petit canard
qu'elle était elle devient le prince
charmant donc ça ça servait aussi mais
c'est vrai que du côté ukrainien il est
évident que le meilleur avocat jusqu'à
présent de l'Ukraine ça a été la Pologne
si on met bien sûr de côté mais c'est un
autre une autre question la
Grande-Bretagne le Royaume-Uni qui l'a
aussi ont été ou même Boris Johnson on
aurait pu en douter et très présent sur
sur l'aide à l'Ukraine voilà ces images
qui sont importantes symboliques qu'on a
vu quand même tout à l'heure on avait
deux chefs d'État se prendre se serrer
dans les dans les bras encore plus
importants quand on sait et quand on se
rappelle que les deux pays n'ont pas
toujours été amis non et c'est un bel
exemple si vous voulez par rapport à la
manière dont le pouvoir russe pas
uniquement Poutine mais le pouvoir russe
considère l'histoire on voit bien qu'il
y a quelque chose de fossilisé dans leur
conception de l'histoire quand Poutine
dit que
à qui est-ce il y a des nazis ou des
néo-nazis
tout d'abord on peut se demander si il y
croit ou s'il n'y croit pas mais dans le
cas où il y croit parce que certains y
croient et bien cela veut dire qu'on
considère que l'histoire a été en
quelque sorte cryogénisée depuis 1945 et
que rien n'a changé et là que se
passe-t-il oui il y a eu des relations
très très exécrables on peut dire dans
la mesure où pendant la guerre la
Deuxième Guerre mondiale les
nationalistes ukrainiens qui Parentis
soviétisme travaillait collaboré avec
les nazis et bien ils ont lancé la
chasse au Polonais ils ont massacré des
Polonais massacrés des Polonais Juifs
massacrées des Juifs Ukrainiens des
juifs russes etc et il y a eu quelque
chose de très très
finalement très très amère de la part
des Polonais disons pour que l'histoire
soit équitable qu'avant cela la Pologne
qui avait dans son territoire une partie
de l'Ouest ukrainien dont notamment le
vif qui s'appelait à l'époque où a
pratiqué une politique de polonisation
qui a été très rude aussi c'était pas
des massacres mais on peut dire qu'il y
avait des quelque chose qui n'ont pas
qui valait mais qui était quand même
très très forte et ça bah finalement
grâce au travail de l'histoire grâce au
travail de chercheurs issus des deux
pays ça se surmonte ça fait
qu'aujourd'hui on est capable aussi bien
du côté ukrainien que du côté polonais
de dire on oublie rien de ce qui a été
terrible mais on arrive à passer
au-dessus c'est un petit peu aussi
l'histoire de la relation
franco-allemande mais elle est d'autant
plus étonnante qu'elle s'est produite
entre deux pays qui sortaient
précisément de l'orbite soviétique avec
tout ce que cela suppose d'habitude à
camoufler à occulter à cacher les choses
avec tout ce que vous venez dire Gautier
on est en mesure de se poser notre
question finalement on voit les Polonais
les Ukrainiens se rapprocher encore plus
on a vu hier la Finlande rejoindre
l'OTAN 31e nation argent de l'Alliance
Atlantique Nord la contre-offensive
l'offensive de Vladimir Poutine est-ce
qu'elle s'avère pas être
contre-productive au final si mais parce
que alors il y a des il y a des formes
de détestation russe qui sont index on
peut dire il véritable aussi par exemple
par rapport à la Pologne vous l'entendez
qu'en mettrait prend la parole
généralement il y a toujours un point
sur la Pologne qui est traité plus bas
que terre bien donc ça c'est ça fait
partie de ces espèces de psychologie
figée des peuples mais il y a aussi le
fait que pour la Pologne et les
Ukrainiens aujourd'hui à cause de
l'offensive de l'invasion de Poutine en
Ukraine tout ce qui ressemble à la
Russie de près ou de loin et c'est ça le
danger d'ailleurs y compris vis-à-vis de
russe qui eux ne marchent pas dans la
combine de Poutine mais il y a une
espèce de de Bronka de détestation là
aussi qui fait qu'au fond effectivement
Poutine père l'Ukraine les Polonais ça
fait longtemps qu'ils avaient perdu mais
il y avait des millions en Pologne qui
n'étaient pas anti-rus je crois que
maintenant c'est terminé donc voilà là
où Poutine aurait pu jouer un rôle en ce
sens qui l'aurait pu bâtir une Russie
qui aurait été éventuellement attrayante
de par un modèle social par exemple non
non seulement il a pas bâti ce système
les Russes empathissent et en plus il
n'a rien fait pour finalement
attraper les cœurs et fabriquer une zone
d'influence qui souhaite une zone
d'influence autre que militaire merci
beaucoup Gauthier pour le